um all right so what so what's the story
today [ __ ] there
no more black holes with nasa so nasa
they have some terms like eskimo what
are does any do we know them
nasa is rio okay i'll do this as luke st
simon
nasa is putting itself on notice
for some some heavenly body names like
what are they eskimo what is it
eskimo nebula that is not acceptable
so okay eskimo nebula so the new name is
going to be what like david tell would
say snow mexican nebula
yes that's a good one that's a good
suggestion nasa are you listening
also siamese twins galaxy you're on
notice
you're no longer siamese twins because
these names have their roots
they have their [ __ ] roots in
colonialism and we're unnoticed
we're on [ __ ] notice yeah so okay so
those are out so listen so that solves
racism there
it's some [ __ ] planet some star a
hundred billion light years away now
we're
we're not gonna call it the [ __ ]
sesame chicken twins whatever the [ __ ]
we call it
yeah we're not gonna pretend like the
meaning of words don't change and you
know it's like shakespeare said what's
the name
the words change it doesn't matter
nobody nobody was thinking oh my god
they use siamese twins or eskimos
this is nasa just trying to gain some
points and some of those kids even
telescopes yeah they just want people
off their back on hey look what we did
we did something good now
don't try to cancel us go look someplace
else nobody gives a [ __ ]
it's all hollow it's perfunctory it's
not real nobody cares
is this a troll move or are they do are
they serious
i think i think they're serious right
yeah i mean it's hard to tell
i mean this is what you get this is what
you get this is where we're at
i mean so the kid's still alive and he's
still in office and they want to put him
on the mount rushmore now
yeah i mean i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm for it
i'm for trump going on mount rushmore
are you
no i'm not that's not no i'm not well i
know
he i want him to stay on the mount
rushmore in ridgewood and that's it
they can have his little [ __ ] statue
in rudy's and
that's where i draw the line it should
be if you want to take down
like if you want to take down uh a
statue like of george washington you
should have to take down his
face off mount rushmore yeah what if you
know be funny
i mean we'll be funny if you want to go
funny every statue they take down
wouldn't it be funny if he does a law
where he put if you take down a statue
they put up one of trump that they'll
stop taking on the statues real quick
for everyone that goes down they replace
it with a trump statue you don't have to
do the 10-year law for that
if that becomes a law they'll stop
taking all those statues down
yeah yeah i mean because that's a really
that made me laugh hard that they're
trying to get him on there now and
you think he'll be successful no no
obviously not i mean you know
i don't i don't you know not even if he
was a great president which i don't
think he is that's my opinion i don't i
think he's a horrible leader
that's my personal opinion but um you
know and obviously there's some things
that when i hear he did i'm like
you know china i'm kind of on board with
that it depends but
yeah no even even if he was great to go
into mount rushmore first of all there's
no [ __ ] room
second of all the history's got to judge
you you got to let some time go by you
know
yeah yeah i i know i don't know we
should go to mount rushmore do you want
to go
i would love to go should we bring binky
and just shoot it 100
should we just should we bring v and
just tell her it's greece i mean she's
frank's being she doesn't know the
[ __ ] difference
she doesn't [ __ ] care yeah let's
bring her let's bring everybody who
gives a [ __ ] right
well who cares are we almost done
because i'm i'm gonna take a [ __ ]
whereby in the morning it's the morning
show with fumare
bed head all that it's a little bump of
coke to start your day
me and chris the history hyenas we do
the show live
monday through friday nine a.m eastern
if you want to watch it live
or get access to it every day go join at
patreon.com
bay ridge boys it's our channel sign up
at the lowest tier level till july 1st
and then it changes to the 10 level
either way go now
go now